hi everybody
let's talk a little bit
um Centric web application pattern and
this talk will
be introducing signing for Python and
it's by George hang a little bit intro
about Joe Joe is the
CTO and first employee at post it PPC
formerly known as rstudio where he
helped and helped create the art studio
ID and shiny web framework along with
countless complementary tools
competitors just welcome John what is
song
thank you
thanks Vincent
uh today I'm going to talk to you about
shiny from python a package for creating
data Centric web applications in Python
this is an example of a pretty simple
typical shiny app
I'm going to go ahead and click it and
I'll show you the live version
uh on the left we have some parameters
that I can use to um you know affect the
graph on the right this is using Seaborn
and on the back end it's Candice or
polars or something I don't remember
um and on the top here I can show some
uh you know big numbers and uh my
colleague who created this example I
wanted to make sure that I clicked on
the Penguins
it's a lovely art by uh Allison Forst
so shiny is as I said it's for creating
interactive apps and dashboards in
Python and we'll get into some of the
different applications today but I want
to emphasize uh because how many of you
have heard of shiny before
and uh how many of you heard of shiny in
the context of R not python okay I want
to make sure that it's clear because
I've gotten this question shiny for
python is not a wrapper around shining
for R this is not like you have to
install R to use shiny for python shiny
for python is the ground up
re-implementation of Chinese inter icon
and it was designed primarily with data
scientists in mind and that means uh
that's a couple of implications number
one we don't expect you to have web
development skills uh you can do tons
and tons of stuff in Joe python
and it's based on this reactive
programming approach to interactivity
that we specifically chose because it's
easy to get started with and and
relatively hard to make mistakes
on the other hand I personally have been
creating websites and web applications
since 1996. it would be really
frustrating for me personally if day in
and day out I was working on this web
framework that felt lowest common
denominator in any way or that it had
artificial guardrails so if you do have
web development skills you can fully
leverage them to customize or extend
your shiny apps and it seems like even
in data science more and more people
seem to be picking up some of these
skills
and the same reactive programming
Paradigm that is so easy to get started
with it's also powerful and flexible and
deep as I hope to show you today
just to get concrete here this is what a
shiny app looks like in Chinese python
every uh this is like probably the
simplest app is like a Hello World app
basically every shiny app has two main
components there's uh first the user
interface and this is python code that
generates HTML to send to the browser
and in this case it's going to look
something like this so we have
okay
um so in this case we have an input
slider and an output plot and this app
UI variable that it's creating is
literally just HTML like if you were to
print that out of I don't know if that's
what you would see
and the other component is This Server
logic that runs on the server at runtime
and it provides the interactivity of the
app in this case if the user touches the
slider and moves it to a new value this
input.n is automatically updated and
this entire function will run to
generate a new plot that is sent to
whatever spot is designated in the UI fi
of the underscore plot there
so that's the basics of how a shiny app
is built at the bottom is just a single
line to create an app object and assign
it to an app variable
and this is what your user experience
will be like as a developer you're using
vs code here we have a shiny for Python
vs code extension so you can just click
this play button here if you have a
shiny app on the screen and it will run
the shiny app at the bottom uh putting
you in the right virtual environment and
things like that and at the right the
application will appear and as you save
changes to your application python code
it will go ahead and reload
automatically as you expect in 2023 for
a web framework
so
um let me show you a slightly more
complicated example than just that uh
hello world in this example we are using
the astropi astronomy package for python
to create a tool that helps astronomers
know when are the best time to look for
these specific celestial objects that
they're interested in observing this
will show you when they'll be brightest
in the night sky depending on what day
and what location on Earth you're in
and I'm going to show some code here
don't don't worry if you um you know
don't try to ingest it all I just want
to point out a couple things about this
kind of code so in this uh China UI
we're using some additional features
first of all uh this is an H3 tag and
HTML that means heading level three so
if you know HTML and you're familiar
with HTML5 you can directly access them
by using these python functions that
wrap the equivalent HTML tag
you can use markdown in this case you
know we have a link in the middle that's
using the markdown syntax
and we can have rows and columns that
have varying widths
we have outputs
we have inputs
and if you put all that together you
have a UI that looks like this and one
other thing that I want to point out
when I zoom out there's sort of a shape
right to the code because it's nested
functions there's sort of a shape that
the indentation gives it and there's
like two big chunks here one for the
header and one for the body and I really
love this property that the shape of the
code is reflected in the shape of the UI
and this is this is true in sort of a
hierarchical way
uh so inside of that body there are two
columns and you can see that the shape
of those columns reflected in the shape
of the code and as your apps get larger
and more complicated this is a really
beautiful property because it means it's
easy to find your way to you know the
specific spot in your complex UI where
um where you need to make changes
Okay so
we announced shiny for python about a
little less than a year ago and uh you
know the news made the rounds and on the
our data science Reddit uh subreddit uh
I think we had a pretty pretty typical
range of reactions uh some people were
really excited
um but other people
look at this
but it's just so easy to throw something
up the streaming how many people here
have heard of streamlined
okay how many people have used streams
okay so so a few of you
and streamit has this reputation for
being just so easy and I want to examine
that unpack that a little bit so imagine
that you have a script.pi a totally
normal linear python script that is
doing some data analysis uh let's say
you're loading some data you are
cleaning a little bit and then you're
previewing a pandas data frame and then
plotting it
the promise of streamlit is that you can
take pretty much that exact uh script
sprinkle in some streamlit to add some
UI and boom you have now an interactive
you know data product or what have you
uh and contrast that to shiny which
if you've never seen shiny before even
what I just showed you clearly shiny
wants you to put code in the places
where it tells you to so it is a
different approach
and um
this this approach that they have of
being able to write shiny uh
streamlabouts in the same way you write
Python scripts there's a very specific
way they make this possible
uh streamless architecture allows you to
write off the same way you write playing
Python scripts to unlock this
streamlined apps have a unique data flow
anytime something must be updated on the
screen streamlit re-runs your entire
python script from top to bottom
and let me be clear uh it is it is easy
I made four simple streamlit apps uh it
is unbelievably easy
um you know you you could learn
streamlit by accident you could learn
you could write a screen without falling
down the stairs I mean it is really
really easy
um and they also have really nice
looking output I mean it's pretty hard
to make a bad looking streamlin app
also has limitations that that are quite
obvious and
um especially the early versions of
stream like you had this pretty slow
performance because it's always
executing the entire thing again and
again and pretty soon you need to start
being pretty deliberate about caching
values and uh and you have pretty
limited uh opportunities for
interactivity other than like changing
parameters the whole thing kind of
rebuilt
so
streamlit added some capabilities uh
called caching callbacks and session
State and as people develop in their
streamlit Journey they find themselves
relying more and more on these
techniques and uh this is where I sort
of uh I'm out you know the combination
of this beautifully elegant top to
bottom execution model plus these other
features I think this combination is
actually quite dangerous and um I'm not
gonna
elaborate too much more on this this is
not a talk about streamlined but um I
just want to make it clear that this is
not something that I made up um I came
to this conclusion by looking at the
feedback that streamlits most rabid fans
were uh were giving them so uh in the
big picture context I see one critical
issue for streamlit the top to bottom
rerun on every interactive interaction
Paradigm uh maintaining state becomes
really difficult and um there are just
multiple examples where people found
this model at first super simple and
then ultimately
um kind of painted them into a corner
so what we've tried to do with shiny and
this reactive approach
um is to have a paradigm that's both
easy to get started with and it scales
it scales as the complexity of your
app's scale it scales as um the kinds of
things you want to do to extend your
apps increase
and over the last 10 years
as shiny for R has proliferated on these
same ideas of reactivity you've seen
people build a rather complex data apps
indeed
and a lot of the time
if you you know talk to our our users
and customers who are getting the most
value of out of shining they're often
um building rather complex not just a
simple dashboard not just a simple uh
you know model demonstrator but really
using shining for those things yes but
also integrating into you know critical
uh workflows
and this idea of reactivity that was
really in the kernel that started
shining over the last 10 years it's been
unbelievable to me how fertile this
ground is for new ideas that these small
reactive Primitives that we've been
working with since 2012 really can be
combined in all these interesting ways
and you know features like this just
sort of fall out left and right and even
after 10 years last week getting ready
for this talk my colleague Winston Chang
and I discovered a new way to use
reactivity to interact with uh async
python generators in a way that made
you'll see one of our demo applications
possible
okay
uh so now I'd like to launch into some
demos and it's 2020 for me what is uh
Tech talk without some kind of large
language model demo right
um so this is a package that
um Winston has been working on that
basically uh makes it easier for him to
scratch his own itch of playing with uh
open ai's chat topt API
so this is a super simple shining out
that you can see here we're importing
this cat module that's new and uh with
one line of UI and one line of server
and this is where
I hope the API
works well today oops
no
stop it
okay with one line of UI one line of
server I have a chat gbt interface so at
like why is the sky
and the fact that this text is streaming
in this is that thing that we're
applying with we're facing generators
um you know it's chat GPD so why is the
sky blue as a wrap
uh so really easy but um
this is not that interesting if we're
just inserting an island of Chachi VT
into a shiny app right what we really
want to do is be able to interact with
uh and and mess with the conversation
between uh Chaturbate and the user uh so
for this next example
um
so uh Winston again uh I'm taking on
Winston I guess this demo session
Winston recently bought a Samsung
induction range he really wanted me to
tell you guys he bought a fancy blue uh
induction range and um this range is
pretty new and chachibichi uh gbd 3.5 is
only current up to September 2021
something like that so um despite having
a PhD he was not able to figure out how
to set the time
on the clock of this new stuff so
what this application lets you do is
take a PDF so in this case the Samsung
induction range uh user manual
and uh and you upload it to this
document and now uh it's indexing it's
it's generating embeddings and when I
ask a question it's going to send a
context to catch EBT so I can say uh how
do I set that clock
that's at the time
on the clock
give me a list of this
okay great and now our
um
our clock can stop flashing 12.
so in this in this example
um you know we had to change the uh the
payload that's being sent to chat gdt
without having to interfere with the
user experience so that's one thing that
this that this package lets you do
uh and then one more chat gbt example
than Amazon
so this one's a little different in that
there are two chat gbts that I've
embedded in this one app
and uh it's it's really fun to to uh
you know sort of compare as you um have
one conversation you can talk to like
another model and ask it different
things but
um let's play 20 Questions
I'll ask
or I'll guess
okay
and uh this app has this mode where you
can have these two uh models talk to
each other so let's play 20 Questions
you guess first or go ahead and yes and
I can click this converse with self and
every time a response comes back from
one of these uh conversations it'll be
directed to the other side
so now we are watching uh chat TPT play
20 Questions with itself uh is it an
object yes it's an object is it commonly
found yes is this sort of there's a lot
of yeses this is a little bit suspicious
I should have turned the temperature up
I guess
um can it be used for cooking food yeah
food is it made out of metal all right
this is something yes what is with all
honestly this doesn't usually happen
this seems very ripped
is it a frying pan
come on okay
so that doesn't usually happen uh but uh
this does usually happen
um
[Music]
I actually don't have anything else
planned it's gonna be 20 minutes
you never know what's going to come out
yesterday when I tried this it was just
smiley emoji and that was it was that
person
all right probably possibly like two
dollars
um so this package is available at this
QR code it's super super wet cement I
mean like I think this has existed for
like a total of four business days now
so uh definitely uh you know API can
change and things like that but super
fun to play around with
um okay
so for my next demo
uh this is using
um
a demo that an example that came from
Folly so this is a plotly uh widget on
the right here showing a 3D
visualization of Brownian motion now
Brownian motion is like the random
motion of a particle on a surface or in
a in a voluminous air or something like
that and I can hit new data here to
generate new samples uh new random
samples and some of these look really
cool and some of them
like this one it's a little harder to
see what's going on just because of the
random angle that the that the camera
happens to be at
now because this is uh plotly they have
this feature where you can click and
drag and that's cool right
um but just for fun for this example uh
we're gonna do something different
so I'm using the Google media pipe
library to track the position of my hand
so um so Google's doing all the heavy
lifting like detecting the blend of
marks on my hand uh but shiny is
calculating a normal Vector shooting out
of my palm and then using that uh to
determine where that where the camera
angle goes
and the reason I show you this besides
you know just that's kind of fun
um is this feature here this smooth
tracking so if I turn this off
this is what this demo originally looked
like
and uh you know when I got this working
I was like oh my gosh this is amazing
and my my uh my son is a senior in high
school and uh it's gonna be a computer
science major next year I was like come
over and come look at this like he was
like why is it so jittery
on graceful um
but you know uh it's a good question
like why is it so jittery and it's
generic because sensors are jittery
right um but I thought it was an
interesting question can we make it not
so jittery so we tried a couple things
we tried
um only registering movement if it was
over a certain number of pixels and that
was like a complete mess it was super
stuttering and slow uh and then we
thought like what if we just uh
average over the last five samples that
we collect and that's that's the
approach here it's just a simple mean
over the last five samples and um and
it's works great super smooth and what's
interesting about this
um oops
what's interesting about this is
[Music]
um
number one it took about 10 minutes to
implement that smoothing in 30 something
lines of code but what this is is
actually not a smoother for this app
this is a generalized smoother for any
reactive value or Source in shining so
that means that any kind of input that
you have in shiny that's that's fast and
noisy you can apply this function tell
it how many samples you want to smooth
over and provide your own algorithm for
how you take n samples and collapse them
into one in my case I was doing a meme
but you can do whatever you want
um with with this short snippet of code
we have generalized smoothing available
in any shiny Active Care to use
and uh that's kind of what I was talking
about
you know we keep discovering these new
applications of this technology called
reactive programming
okay just a couple more features I want
to talk about uh one is uh shinyvive
shining live is the combination of
shining and the power of webassembly uh
via the the uh pretty famous at this
point piadite project so if you haven't
heard of it piadite is python running
inside of your web browser using
webassembly
and uh what this lets you do
is have an experience like this where we
have this web page loaded
and there's actually nothing behind this
web page other than HTML CSS and
JavaScript now there is no server
running a python python is running
entirely within the browser
and uh this is just showing a a CPU
real-time CPU graph well to be fair one
thing you cannot do in the browser is
monitor the host computer CPUs so this
is fake data
um but if you imagine some other
streaming uh you know data source the
same kind of techniques would apply we
have a canvas style data table at the
bottom and
um and we can change this
this color palette uh to to have
different color Maps um and this one is
not awesome uh so
let's go ahead and remove that as an
option so we can come here and
delete this
and if I press play now it is reloaded
and uh and my update has taken effect
so
um pretty nice to be able to just come
to this webpage anyone could you don't
have to install shiny on your local
anything you can just start playing with
shiny through the shinylive.io website
and if you like what you've done here
you can even share it through a URL so
you can
um
if you want to send this to a friend
that you want to see the code then you
can use this link and they have
basically the same editing experiences
you did
or you can click here and say like no I
want this just to feel like a full on
application and it hides all the Chrome
and just shows the app
so um the nice thing about this is that
the computation now is all happening on
the browser so uh you can actually use
this technology to deploy shiny apps to
any static web host you can put it on
GitHub Pages or or what have you instead
of having to pay for you know for Roku
we also have um free free hosting but if
you wanted to put on any static blog
post you could
and you can also easily embed these
kinds of shiny applications in quarto if
you haven't heard of Porto it is a way
of stitching together uh narrative
through markdown and computations and
outputs of computations all together in
beautiful documents um my colleague JJ
O'Leary will be talking about that later
in this afternoon and
um what this lets you do is it lets you
combine these applications either there
like this or with a full editing
experience directly into uh your your
documents and reports
super easy to do
and we like that feature so much that we
actually use Porto to build our
documentation website so when you're
learning shiny all of our examples take
place in these little editors and all of
this is using Cordo and shiny live
uh one more feature we this does not
this is not available yet
um this is something that we're working
on but I was really excited about it so
I wanted to at least give you a preview
um we have a shiny UI editor that's
being developed that is a way to drag
and drop your way to creating shiny UI
so instead of writing the UI code that I
showed you with nested function calls
you can use controls on the left drag
them onto this surface in the middle and
then use the pane on the right to modify
properties and all this is doing is just
writing the same code you would write so
the end result is not a lot different
than if you were to write it by hand so
you know you can change some properties
on the slider here what you're seeing in
the middle is just sort of a wireframe
version of the application it's not High
Fidelity but in the lower right it's
rendering a preview that is showing the
live application and you can click it to
see what your application actually looks
like so still early days for this thing
but we expect to be rolling it out in
the coming months and we're super
excited about making it easier for
people to create especially if you have
if you're building dashboards that have
a bunch of rectangles on it to get
spacing exactly right and to get the
right proportions it's one of those
things that's uh easier when you're
dragging yeah and looking at it in real
time then um then writing the code
okay that is it for me
um if you are interested in writing
powerful reactive web applications I
highly encourage you go to
shiny.plus.com Pi we have examples and
lots of Articles and reference
documentations there that QR code is to
the main website and if you're
interested in the source code of my
examples minus the chat ones
um they're at Pi data Seattle 2023.
um and maybe uh in the middle of
questions I'll switch over to to show
the other side again so uh yeah thank
you
hi um I've never used shiny but I was
just wondering if you could characterize
how if I have like some data on the back
end that I want to reference or plug
into this was I have a file that I found
a couple hundred thousand rows of
data
what should I think about or do we have
a capacity
yeah sure uh I think the question was if
you have data on the back end that's
maybe a couple hundred thousand rows or
really I think the question you're
asking is like how do you get your data
into this thing and what size
limitations you need to worry about
um so you can use any sort of python
code you want to load your data
um and uh you know our example apps use
uh pandas and polars and TV and
um pretty much it's up to you how you
want to load your data
now there are a couple things that are
worth talking about as far as
um you know scalability and things like
that go number one uh as a general rule
your data stays on the server so if
you're looking at a bunch of plots you
made in Seymour
um and uh and that's it then you know
you could load you know gigs of data and
none of it is transferred over the wire
just the actual outputs that the user is
doing and that may sound obvious but
that's not true for all python data
science Frameworks
now there are I think that the main
thing that you'll have to worry about is
uh number one is memory consumption uh
so
um in order to get a good performance
you
um want to not be going back to like
leading a huge CSV every time the user
kind of touches anything so uh by
default
shining has these reactivity features
actually on the screen here so it's
react to calc
this is sort of a way to do very smart
caching of uh of your your data as it
changes so in general it'll cache the
last copy like the current copy of your
data that you're displaying so if you're
loading a gigantic uh data frame and
that is the result of your reactive calc
expression the shiny is going to hold
one copy of that in memory uh if you do
a bunch of aggregation on it before you
return it then shiny will just hold the
aggregated values which could be you
know
um much much smaller so uh and also I
think as your data gets bigger than just
like anything in uh you know python data
analysis you start to look at sort of
out of memory things you start to look
at things like duct TV or using you know
a football database or a live system or
something like that and maybe not just
loading csps into memory
yeah I'm curious uh how easy was it to
move shiny over python like python has
kind of a very has been used for one
moment for a long time compared to our
I'm just kind of curious if you have any
feelings on that yeah how hard was it to
move shiny over to python um I think it
was one of those things that seemed
really scary until we started and then
it went very quickly
um
and uh that includes having to uh really
learn like Python's type annotation
system wasn't something that existed the
last time I really did any real python
uh and that was something our whole team
you know had to pick up and get good at
um but you know I'd say like 90 of it
was uh like surprisingly fast and then
every once in a while there was
something that like creating the
reference documentation an ungodly
amount of time like so they were like
surprising things that ended up taking
the other 90 of the time
yeah I was expecting that up to three
minutes to get to that question no no no
it's it's a really good question and I
almost um addressed it in my talk and
then I just thought I'd leave it for a
question
um well
every web framework
has its own opinions about what's
important and we all make different
payoffs and
um
in the particular case of Dash the the
most opinionated thing they did uh was
they made the server stateless
and um that means that
there is no memory in dash between one
implication of a callback and another
so um it's kind of like to me that has
always puzzled me as the choice that
they made because
um
it has such it introduces uh such
annoying limitations for the app author
and really mostly has a marginal benefit
for the people who ultimately have to
deploy the app
um I actually was curious about this I
was going to make this assertion that it
you know has this like big downside and
like fairly marginal uh upside and I
think we have a lot of customers that um
use shiny for R and dash for Python and
I don't think anyone has ever said oh
and like we love that Dash it's
serverless like it just I mean stateless
like it turns out that it just doesn't
matter for the vast majority of
especially data oriented uh applications
um but listen I'm here to learn so if
you are a dash user and you love Dash
and I'm wrong and you know you love the
stateless aspect of it
um then absolutely please come talk to
me at the positive Booth
um but I will say
um I think when people start to realize
how much state is being transferred to
the server every single time you you
know touch anything like if you upload a
CSV you're really just holding it in the
client and every single output that
renders every single time they render
you have to send that data to the server
in every xhr call and that that's just
like a really surprising trade-off to me
um so uh In fairness Dash plotly has a
page about like they know this is a
problem so they have a page like here
are all these mitigations but to me like
that exact problem that they have
workarounds for was the heart of shiny
like the heart of shiny is that you have
this state that they're going to want to
use again and again as you tweak through
you know the different possibilities of
your analysis and uh what we treat it as
core they treat it as sort of um you
know a little more of an after class
so
sure sure
yeah so the question was
um at at your work if they uh embed
bokeh or really integrate bokeh
applications into larger applications
that are written in flask uh so almost
uh shiny is not based on flask but based
on the newer asgi Frameworks so uh it is
based on Star lab or fast API if you've
heard of that so you can combine shining
with fast API applications in exactly
the same way that you can combine okay
with
um with flask that being said before
existing flask applications the other
way you could go which people do with
shiny for R is to aggregate at the proxy
layer so you would run an engine X
server in front of both servers and then
use that to basically like map Chinese
onto a certain your shiny app onto a
certain URL path I'm making it sound
more complicated than it is
yeah yeah okay uh there's yeah over here
in front so if you are
um
yeah so the question was
um if we're a stateful server how do we
handle multiple people accessing the
server at the same time uh and that is
an excellent question
um there are a couple ways we do that so
let me first talk about multiple people
hitting the same server right
um or the same python process
So This Server function is actually
invoked once per visitor or once per we
call it a session but it's like a
browser tab basically uh so uh each
um each visitor that arrives gets their
own uh copy of this input output in
session so everything that you do inside
of the server function is isolated to
that one user but a really interesting
uh consequence of this architecture that
I that I really love is that you can put
things here
uh so you can put like reactive objects
here and then they're actually shared by
all users so you you can decide what
things are Global what things are
specific to each user
um now the other question you might be
wondering is if you have multiple
servers in a cluster uh how do you you
know there's there's there's something
in memory on a particular server how do
you make sure that it's about it
um so for that we just ask that you turn
on sticky flow balancing which after you
build a balancer has that feature uh and
pretty much pumps off
what
is there any obfuscations like
underlying data that like like
yeah or anything like that can you
like is it easy to like I guess respect
and like it's just all the undergoing
data or is there some
material oh man like
can you imagine if I answered like yes
it's easy to get at the underlying data
that'll be real bad uh no so so for a
shiny
um it is at the end of the day it's a
web application so um the messages that
are going back and forth over the wire
are the inputs and the outputs the
underlying data the underlying code
remains locked away on the server
um the one exception to that is the
shiny live mode where everything's
running on the client well in that case
everything's being shipped to the client
so if you have hard-coded a password
into your shiny application and then
ship it via shiny live to the browser
well yeah you've made a mistake but if
you hosted any of the traditional ways
where python is running on the server
and the front end is just you know
showing pictures and giving you inputs
then everything is perfectly safe just
the same way it would be in flask the
same way it would be in Django or any
other
yeah
uh so you're comparing it to flask and
Jayco fasting guide is the cicd like
like this looks like really from a
developer who's a active perspective
super easy to get up and running um the
The Logical next question is okay now I
need people at my organization to use
this I needed to deployed I need to get
rid of updates improvements is that kind
of standard or any additional
considerations Beyond like terrific
typical batch API development and
deployment yeah yeah you sound like
someone who works for a living that's a
very uh practical uh and important
question so um the question was yeah
this seems great for whoever's writing
the application but when it comes to the
time to deploy it and uh integrated into
cicd uh pipelines and and keep it up and
keep it stable is there anything that
you need to be aware of uh so in terms
of the deployment it feels pretty much
like a typical uh fast API type app uh
however
um
uh I'd say if you write a traditional
Django or fast API type app uh the
testing can be easier because really
what you're right writing uh for most of
those sort of lower level web Frameworks
is a series of end points uh and with
shining all this interactivity this is
happening over a websocket there's no
reason why that's not inherently
testable but like most people in most
organizations do not have a lot of
experience testing websocket-based
applications so I will say uh we have
been using playwright if you use
playwright or Cypress as a testing
Frameworks they work awesome uh and play
array will even let you inspect a laptop
websopic traffic as it goes through but
yes if you have people that are used to
testing Django apps uh specifically the
testing aspect and also the load testing
aspect it's probably going to throw them
for a loop for a little bit uh but other
than that I I mean and to be honest
the turnaround times on building these
kinds of apps for people who know a
little bit of shiny like it is so
dramatically different than what it is
for using uh I mean and by the way the
same is true for streamlined and dash
you were talking about a different order
of magnitude uh velocity versus
um using sort of these lower level
Frameworks that
um
you know people get that there are going
to be these kinds of trade-offs where
you know the wires are not quite as
visible and again instrument them quite
as well
uh yeah is one final question or I know
you guys are out that's fine
thank you very much
foreign